[Music]
yeah oftentimes when people talk about
sacred texts for many people the sort of
thing that you say to show how serious
you are is well you know we take it you
know we take it literally but that
actually has caused an extraordinary
amount of destruction in the world so I
I begin with I try to take it literally
so if it's a poem and it's a poem and if
it's a letter who wrote it and when did
they write it and who are they writing
it to what was the world like at that
time if it was history but the writer is
kind of winking along the way like this
is what I'm really saying then you take
it with that subtlety and nuance and
even humor so all religious texts have
to be interpreted and the really
dangerous thing is when someone says I'm
not giving you my opinion I'm just
telling you what it says because that's
actually their opinion if you deny human
agency it generally leads to some sort
of oppression or exploitation so
everything gets way more interesting
when you start reading it literally
because you then don't have to do those
awkward explanations one of my one of
the greatest examples of this is there's
this anxious story about Jonah who gets
swallowed by a fish not a whale of fish
because it says in the ancient text and
so the question often becomes a debate
about whether or not a guy really got
swallowed by a fish and you have the
literalists going it says he got
swallowed by fish he got swallowed by a
fish and then you have the others going
no it's a larger metaphor but what's
interesting is the story begins the
Assyrians were the worst neighbors they
were the cruel oppressors who had made
life miserable and so this man Jonah is
told go and bless Nineveh and Nineveh
was the capital of Assyria so the story
begins with a man being told go bless
your worst most heinous enemy and he
doesn't he goes the other direction he
runs away which I
think the original audience would have
cheered this man Jonah on you you go the
other direction whatever you do don't go
bless the person who has made your life
a living hell so he eventually gets on a
boat there's a storm he's thrown
overboard and he's swallowed by a fish I
think the power of the story is not
arguing about whether or not he was
swallowed by a fish I think the story
was told to a group of people to
confront them with how they cannot
forgive their worst enemy and will the
past and the wounds that you have
suffered define you and hold you back or
can you forgive can you move towards
your enemy not with violence but with
love do the things that have happened to
us define us or is there a love that can
transcend even this so this would be a
classic example to me where there's an
ancient text in a story where you can in
your attempt to prove defend it
literally actually avoid the more
interesting questions of the heart that
I think are the questions the
storyteller is trying to get at and yes
in our world to this day taking some of
these texts literally has caused so much
violence you read the ancient texts you
also use your mind you listen for what
new thing might be happening in the
world you read it as a fully orbed
experience and then it actually gets
quite inspiring
you